happy post-christmas reject nation I'm
Greg Alva John is me we're gonna watch
George Lucas and Harrison Ford react to
baby Yoda and McClung key deep fake saga
Collider videos is killing it or the
George Lucas ones I watched the one
where Lucas is camping out at Burbank 16
that was awesome hilarious watched it on
my own don't react every one of these
but I was like you know what I like to
react to this one then after sharing
this we're gonna be shooting the
reaction to the final episode of the
Mandalorian that should be up mañana so
keep a lookout for that subscribe and
click that notification bell see you
notified when our mando reaction is up
let's get into this I enjoy it I enjoy
it Collider I do because I get to say
what's on my mind and I have to worry
about the mouse coming out on me yeah so
this is a baby Yoda just what people are
calling it but really there's no there's
no species for it you know I never named
it so the the balls on Jon Favreau and a
falow need to decide that they know what
this is is very curious to see where
they go with us well you know who you
know who'd really hate this as much as I
do is Harrison Harrison for actually
bumped into him not that long ago I
should I should see what he thinks about
this they're not paying me anything
oh god I'm bored got nothing else going
on yeah well just know if they were
saying in the nineties well you know
remember all you my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's the clash yeah yeah what have you
been doing these days haven't seen you
in a while
yeah I know what you're up to that ring
that smile did you know because I need
to go to a gala you know I always loved
about you is when you do those crazy
hands and you know when you're in pain
or something yeah that's great I love it
I love it this is Harrison Ford hands
used to joke about that are you [ __ ]
yeah my carbonate the carbon I was
actually based on we I were walking by
your your trailer and I'd seen you
pinching one out and I so that's an
interesting face and so we just had you
do that same face it's the key was to
never let it out yeah I mean you didn't
you did on that last day that's the one
we kept well we kept it we kept it so
the ideas in this new Star Wars TV show
it's called the Mandalorian there's no
bomb a fetish Boba Fett oh yeah whoo
yeah ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
let me ask you something yeah I'm pretty
high myself do you have somewhere that
spaceship become that oh I love that
stuff listen after this family get hives
the kite with you or I go to a galaxy
far far away
you know it is kind of cute you like it
so goddamn Muppet they did it again me
that's not CG well we made all lose it
you know remember Jar Jar Binks from the
great creations in history it's a sock
puppet we don't really know what species
it is the whole idea was we didn't know
everything you know I used to talk about
that oh yeah oh yeah well I remember
that part then you fall asleep a lot I
mean you know why did I come back here
sorry so these are memes I guess you
know if memes are mmm mean meme it's
like a well that's good yeah I mean how
do you say mean with you or if you're
scared or angry someone just took all
your money mean it's right there now
you're you're flying through hyperspace
and uh-huh you go tell Chewie to punch
it but you say it as mean you need it we
should make another picture George I
don't think so
I'll give you a 40 million raise a jerk
all right how much you got paid for you
believe this isn't a TV show for insane
the whole show I mean it's rotten it's
it's making me watch soup I think I say
idea maybe it's a Campbell's has a sort
of a deal sponsorship deal with us
Owen Roth Oh Calista doing oh yeah she's
great
your wife oh yeah eat listen Frank Oz
was high as a kite this is they do know
you sitting you look at you yeah never
the white shops we had on day go back
what did this shoot on that well you
were that planted they never left me
they they said they're no no we're not
shooting that well I was surprised you
know I figured you were on the set
because they said the fog machines been
broken for three weeks
yeah it was it was this one over here we
found you family she baked treats
tongues with that lizard remember and
you know you smoked the lizard
there's no where's Harrison he's licking
one of the toads on the set oh Jesus
we had fun I know there were there were
some good part we had fun we had fun
there were some good parties so yamen
shame on you there it is
oh yeah there's like three different
things I guess she's on the Ellen shows
at Ellen forever [ __ ] freak you out
yes you
here put on the shoe all that box not
that your talked about Ellen's box
originally we were supposed to the older
charger and we were talk about make
another movie story of Jar Jar sort of a
downtrodden character Oh an aged what
was an aged you know stories lived in
kind of as a family maybe lost his
families
yeah yeah anyway so we had a Morgan
Freeman came in and actually really
tested for that baby
[Music]
hashtag raising baby Yoda I want to kill
myself I want to commit seppuku why the
[ __ ] they killed I thought you killed me
I did this is a Mandalorian really good
just leave us yeah he feels good right
guards leave us girls bring us that bad
guy brother yeah
leave us we're gonna get nuts in here
we're gonna get high and watch your
friends follow the trash okay
[Music]
George I've got the stuff
oh yeah yeah right yes sorry I'm gonna
taste so this is of the original Star
Wars pictures things that I was unhappy
with that could change were you unhappy
well there are certain things creatures
and things that never worked but this is
the Han Solo and Greedo scene though I
think I finally got a break first
longtime watches wait for it wait for it
[ __ ] my funky funky changes it right my
coffee so much better this my clunky
yeah remember you shot person the
original I changed it so that's he would
he would shoot first and now you shoot
at the same time but now I cleverly put
in the clunky angry clunky she's not
giving you giving you the business in
you had enough Oh God George we get
available that was still can there's
time they can D age you remember her
little we didn't we used to take a
little nap yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
did y'all see what George when she was
carrying a little such a great
impression so great Wow oh man that was
awesome it dawned on me when I was
watching this that I have seen so many
Harrison Ford interviews a love old man
Harrison Ford as he gets older it's he's
just more and more entertaining yeah and
I've seen this doesn't care as much
yeah and I've seen so many George Lucas
interviews and it hit me something I've
ever actually seen an interview where
they're side by side right next to each
other I don't know who did the Harrison
Ford impersonation but that is a
thousand percent accurate I was so
impressed with that like beyond the
voice the speech pattern the weird like
sense of he doesn't care to be there yet
he's intensely comfortable in his own
skin he's not afraid to get like this
enjoy hey I'm here with George awkwardly
observing everything around him taking
his time with each response and the
little smirks that he would have I
thought were nail he has this thing
where he seems like he finds things that
are amusing or stupid in a funny way the
way he reacts to thing certain things
people do or say same time he has his
way of like his mouth opens and closes
where he seems like he's trying not to
laugh this little smile comes in and out
and beautifully yeah well I think it's
the guy who did obi-wan I think they're
in a couple of those profile shots you
can start to get a sense for whose face
they're stitching Harrison Ford's face
and I feel like it was probably that guy
but uh yeah to get them both together it
creates this almost weird sense of
history that isn't actually there cuz
it's all fake it is believable in an odd
way and it makes these just so much fun
I didn't even realize until halfway
through that we were
even really looking at or commenting on
the memes at all yeah it's just about
yeah watching these to bounce off each
other these two guys who have such a
legacy but are old and pretty much live
a retired life don't really do much now
there's here commenting on whatever the
kids are up to but they're just like a
rambling and ranting I love how they
don't understand what the memes are
confuse over so many things well it's
the dynamic of George giving him
directions periodically of like things
to say now say it like Princess Leia has
given you the business or say it like
this you know and having that go back
and forth to is like an actual game
within the game
their effects on the Lucas are getting
absolutely perfect like when they first
came out you notice it now it looks
insanely perfect Harrison Ford looked a
little bit fake at times but this is the
first time I've seen that Harrison have
you seen the Harrison Ford ones from
them before was the first time I've ever
seen them not in full but I thought it
was yeah this was absolutely a delight
because George Lucas and Harrison Ford
their careers kind of go hand in hand in
so many ways American Graffiti had
Harrison Ford's first like main
supporting role then of course Han Solo
and then Indiana Jones you know this
fact is I'm at the Disneyland recently
and it hit me then it was there was like
there are two rides here two main
attractions now at Disneyland that are
Lucas and Harrison Ford baby now the
Millennium Falcon
then the Indiana Jones ride I actually
want to look up interviews now where the
two of them together in the ruse of them
together now like within the last like
five to ten years or something because I
would love to see something like that
that's the reaction we gonna do next
just only reacting to real interviews
like watching Harrison Ford I just want
what are these every week now I just
want all the different Star Wars cast to
get deep faked well this seems to be the
biggest thing Collider videos is doing
right now I can see why pretty soon
they're gonna can movie talk and
Collider heroes I'm just gonna be a
whole bunch of deep fakes no they should
just combine them they should just have
it be that the deep fake characters are
hosting Collider movie talking to
players they should have them do
Collider live there you know they can
figure out how to deep fake live that
would be amazing yeah avoid the lawsuits
the amount of Star Wars news they got to
cover all the time on Collider movie
talk oh he's so funny
okay squadron movie talk and collateral
or both live shows that'll be really I
mean a segment in and of itself wouldn't
be impossible get on it
yeah great segment put it in the show
the next time I see Deniz zing there
that's what he better be working on
alright guys well make sure to subscribe
to Collider videos they are capitalizing
on the deep fake thing like nobody's
business you can subscribe to the real
rejects click our notification milligan
notify whenever got a youtube video up
catch you guys soon